you know it started with with one little
jog because you you had the back fat you
didn't like it it wasn't like some Grand
ambition that you were going to run
across Australia it was one tiny step
and yeah you know when I asked you about
mantras and you're talking about just
getting to the next Lamppost it's
breaking everything down into really
easily you know repeatable digestible
actions and and you know the levers
really moved through those tiny things
undertaken every day anonymously you're
just a bloke at home going out for a jog
here and there and you strung some
things together that led to something
fantastic but it didn't begin that way
so I think like being humble and and
just getting into the habit of kind of
flexing the muscle of self-care wherever
that instinct or or inspiration is is
leading you is is really the impulse to
pay attention to